Julia Louie Dreyfus reveals she is
battling cancer the veep actress made
the announcement across social media
tweeting one in eight women get breast
cancer today I'm the one remaining
upbeat the 56 year old actress went on
to give thanks for her supportive
friends and family and the fantastic
insurance she has through her Union
adding the bad news is that not all
women are so lucky so let's fight all
cancers and make universal health care a
reality Dreyfuss learned of her
diagnosis the day after her historic
Emmys win et caught up with her on the
red carpet right before the awards show
she addressed the final season of her
hit HBO show using an awful lot of paint
for down there maybe use it for up here
and focus on let's give the people what
they want okay that's really I'm sorry
that was today out of line the show was
gonna end are you prepared for that well
am I prepared I'm as prepared as I can
be it felt like the right decision to
make and I was i wrung my hands about it
but we have a whole other season to
shoot and I think that it feels right
story wise it gives it a finality that
feels really strong as we broke story
this year
et have learned that writers are
currently writing scripts for the final
season of veep
however it is unknown when production
will return